i always thought computers were better
at math and people until i tried to add
0.1 to 0.2 and got an answer
of 0.3000000004 what the hell
javascript is just a toy language so i
figured it was a bug and tried the same
thing in python but it also gave me the
same wrong answer then i discovered that
these languages aren't actually broken
they just do floating point arithmetic
computers have a limited amount of
memory and need to make a trade-off
between range and precision
in javascript all numbers must be stored
within 64 bits that means we can have
integers accurate
up to 15 digits and a max of 17 numbers
after the decimal point it's called a
floating point because there are no
fixed number of digits before or
after the decimal point allowing it to
represent a wide range of numbers both
big and small
the problem is that computers use a base
2 system binary
while humans use a base 10 system that
leads to rounding errors when all the
memory has been used up and that's why
your computer
sucks at math